ladies and gentlemen please welcome one
of my favorite females vanessa bayern
[Applause]
i'm so excited i'm so excited
just love so many of the
amazing characters that you created on
saturday night live i quote you like
every day of my life what was one
character
that rises to the top for you or that
like still resonates every day or that
you're like i just need to be that
person right now i think the person the
character that is the most truly me at
my core is the bar mitzvah boy because
he's the cutest i mean it must feel so
good because
you would just move your mouth in a
certain smile and the whole room would
like go roaring laughter like that must
feel really good it was it was really
fun i mean it took a few tries like i
tried subtle stuff like that before and
it didn't always sometimes the audiences
would be like no thank you
oh i know those crickets on tumblr
they're like
and they're just like no not for us
and you're like comedy is like the drive
home is painful and awkward and
vulnerable yes yes okay so this amazing
show i love that for you is living out a
dream job it's
like a shopping network yes um and um
i i'm just curious like if you weren't a
famous comedian or doing the show like
what job would you pick as a dream job i
actually think that would be it because
i watched a lot of home shopping when i
was a kid and i really loved how they
talked and how they talked about the
products and touched the products and i
um i also i think because i watched it
so much at such a young age it's like a
language i learned
does it ever get actually stuck in your
head like a flight pattern for
performance like i couldn't watch
samantha in sex in the city ironically
because every line i started delivering
yeah yeah yeah well honey did that ever
affect you that way yes exactly exactly
um but okay this is an odd dovetail but
you know it
you love life i'm just going straight
yes okay tell me about your love life is
it true that you're on a dating app yes
i think i'm i think we might be on the
same i think we are have you ever seen
more djs in your life
um
also i'm pretty sure that you have to be
a surfing photographer yeah yeah yeah
and you have to have someone else's kid
yeah in your picture yeah and show your
the uncle yes exactly um but you have to
have a huge dog that's so scary in a way
that's like who's that for yeah and uh
and you have to be a foodie yeah um and
uh and shirtless you have to be sure
that this shirtless photos are so and
there's it's just like
yeah who who is
it's a real it's a tough
uh it's a tough place to be
first of all i don't know if you
experience this too but a lot of times
i'll match with someone and then they'll
never message me oh my god i'm like
wait raise of hands who has had this
happen to them on a dating app
right
i'm like why are you here is it just
like a feather in the cap and then they
move on i'm also like why don't they
feel don't they have better stuff to do
with their time then match with someone
and be like okay and then like go on
like use that moment to like write a
book or
or there's a cafe in japan that's about
this for writers
go there
[Music]